robots I've been talking about this
since I was in like third grade they are
going to take over one day and that day
is coming so DARPA this is the defense
advanced research projects agency that
sounds pretty fancy they have built a
new 6 foot 2 330 pounds aster robot and
what they're gonna do with this thing is
send it into like the nuclear disaster
in Japan where humans can't go or if
there is a earthquake and they have to
send you know and it's gonna do things
that humans can't do or are it's too
dangerous for humans to do let's look at
a little videotape and then we will
analyze the robots
all right I mean it is so obvious to me
this is they're going to take over this
is every science fiction movie that I've
ever loved from 2001 I Robot the matrix
I mean we're gonna build these things
and then a terminator they're gonna be
our masters so I guess my first question
is will you be a loyal servant to your
robot overlord I will destroy all robots
you're gonna be will smith and i will be
destroying all robots with my trusted
rescue dog yep and go call back and hey
you're not the only one who did yeah but
that was amazing you know but you know
they're gonna put some tips in a vagina
on those oh yeah eyes are gonna be
it pretty soon you know that
some of you have it's gonna be a robot
with a gut and a robot mullet but a
t-shirt says no fat chicks no robots
that's actually really hilarious so you
know because it's all nerdy men that are
making these robots so they're gonna
make hot chicks for them to bang and
then all the male robots are gonna be
these fat losers be great they don't
want any competition yeah no but really
do you think I'm so convinced that
within our lifetime these robots are
gonna take over we're in what way we're
just gonna create things that are
stronger than us smarter than us they're
gonna slowly get rid o need us all they
need is our brains and once they have
that yeah it's terminator man it's real
wow so you think the future is here the
future is here the future was yesterday
Wow I don't know where we are now can I
pitch you as a show don't steal it yes
okay and none of your viewers should
steal it okay robot court where the jury
is all robots mmm cuz then we can't hate
you know Jerry number B 572 or whatever
they've been programmed to understand
everything exactly a no antithetical
logic all the logic goes into them and
they spit out the applicant you know a
jury app whatever and and it's just
robot juries that's how we're gonna use
them what about the problem of now like
when the rope when the robots owner dies
over there's a hurricane and there's all
the homeless robots oh no survivors the
Robo hobos do I like
homeless robots who's gonna feed you
look backwards like and then robosexual
zai mean there's a lot of things there's
a lot of things that we reveal those
sexuals should under civil laws they
should have equality yeah you should be
able to get married marriage equality
goes for robots there was a great
episode of futurama know about that they
came in there was trying to marry robot
Jannetty you know it's a slippery slope
because if two dudes can marry then why
can't a guy in a dog I need to marry my
dog on a robotic all right let's not go
back to gay marriage but really am I
being a mite being completely nuts when
you see something like that do you not
see that as just like the future and
these things are gonna be walking around
amongst us I didn't take yeah driving
cars the whole thing although our car
will be a robot so yeah our Cabana are
already computers yeah yeah so that's
we've already I feel like transcended
that yeah um I do feel that once the
robots learn how to use guns and and
give abortions and then we have OB gy
robot um obg Bob lots bummer uh then yes
it will get dangerous but as long as we
can still as humans walk over to the
robot and press power I feel okay so you
write a big power button as long as
there's a big power by any remote cuz
what if they're far away and we're fat
and we're lazy we're Americans we just
want to use our remote to get the robot
we shake the batteries a little bit and
we just turn them off it's like the
clapper she's never yeah don't I mean
I'm sure you guys are posting the matrix
and Terminator and doesn't it seem like
they'll just go to it'll get to a point
where they just won't need us anymore
that will are all of our ways of hating
each other and the waste of energy and
resources robots will be like well they
created us but we don't need those
freaks anymore maybe actually be able to
think and that's the whole thing like
Siri I have conversations with Siri yeah
and I obviously she's programmed to say
quit calling me a yeah but but I
don't know if computers will ever get to
the point where they can actually think
you know like in 2001 where the computer
I don't think it'll ever get to where
they can think well it's not necessarily
that they'll think the way we think but
that they'll build them in such a way
that there
chick will ultimately be like well
humans are no longer necessary that
they're gonna build a system that is so
logical and humans are not what you
Spock's with what happened is we will be
humans will turn into the Middle East
and robots will be America and we'll
always have oil that they need and so
they will be dependent on us forever so
no matter what we do they're always
gonna be like well we're a slave to the
Middle East okay did I just imagine the
law your mom yeah she's giving me a lot
to think about here robot porn rubato
our robot on robotics yeah it's a lot
seriously if we always have something
that they need right then they will
always be beholden to us right that's
just like a woman to get the one but
yeah true exactly what I was gonna say
all right well on that note great show
guys thanks for coming in I'm gonna let
you guys pimp yourselves out directly
into the camera here I want you to talk
to number two okay number two how are
you have a robot that is a robot I've I
am Akira at Kira comedy if you want to
tweet something anti-semitic to me from
France to feel free and I might have a
podcast the mother funny show mother
funny show com so check it out I didn't
know about that podcast yeah not a
mother you're not a mother but you are
funny you are one funny mother funny i
also have a show here on The Young Turks
that one's called the jimmy dore show
it's good youtube slash tyt comedy and
you can check out that show alright well
thank you guys and thank you guys for
watching we have so much to think about
now between robots and dogs and gays and
home I subscribe there's a big red
button down there they just changed it
you can't miss it click it and then this
will just come right to you can you ask
for anything more simple or fantastic I
don't think so all right we'll do it
again next week thanks
you